Let's go next to we're going to go to Sam
from Houston.
Sam from Houston is joining us.
Sam, I would say, what's your name and where
are you calling from?
But I already have that information.
And you're going to have to unmount yourself,
Sam, if you want to chat.
Which which we want.
We want you to.
On mute.
But you do have to on mute yourself.
Sam from Houston, you've got it on mute.
You are mute.
There you go, Sam.
Hey, David.
How are you doing?
Good.
How are you?
I'm doing feel like I ATSDR after that debate.
Right.
So I guess I wanted to get your take on the
biggest way that the left will look at the
debate for Biden spoke yesterday and mostly
from the standpoint.
I guess so.
Whoever is still undecided at this point.
How do you view their reaction, their viewpoint?
So you're saying specifically left wing undecided
people who are politically left, but they're
not sure about voting Biden yet?
Right.
All right.
I mean, listen, this is so speculative and
we really have to wait for the polling.
But my instinct is that there will be some
on the left and they're very loud on Twitter
and on Reddit.
There will be some on the left who will say
Biden stumbled and bumbled.
And we can't have this guy in office.
But then they're going to vote.
The guy in who talked about Biden's sons cocaine
problem and said he needs that the proud boys
to stand by for after the election.
Like that's how that's who you're going to
go with.
So I think we shouldn't be be tricked into
thinking that a lot of the left is reacting
to Biden by saying, wow, now I'm voting Trump
because of that debate.
I think that for the left, remember, most
undecideds aren't left wing.
Undecideds tend to be center and center right
who don't pay too much attention.
But for left wing undecideds.
I think Biden was stable and Trump was a petulant
child.
And it probably helps Biden with the left
wing undecideds.
There's very few of them, though.
Yeah, I think that that's the best way to
look at last night because of the fact that
it was just.
Dreaming and is there anything that you would
advise the next moderator for the next debate?
Because Chris Wallace and the moderate moderator
needs to be able to control the microphones
of the candidates, both candidates would have
to agree to it.
And it's not going to happen.
So what I think the next best thing can be
is the moderate.
This could make the debate last twice as long.
But the moderator should enforce that.
If Trump interrupts Biden, Biden's time stops
and it gets taken away from Trump.
So, for example, and it's very hard to do.
If Biden is supposed to get two minutes and
Trump talks for thirty of it, Biden gets another
30 and that 30 counts against Trump's next
time slot.
They're not going to allow it.
They're not going to do it.
It's logistically difficult.
But what else can you do?
Oh, I would I would love that.
I think that that would be the best thing
to be able to cut.
One of the both of their mikes off because
it was bad.
But I think they both need to agree to it
and they're never going to watch it much the
next week.
Do you think.
Yeah.
You're sort of breaking up.
You're sort of breaking up, Sam.
But I know that you're saying the Carmela
Pence debate will be here for it.
I think Carmela is going to crush him.
Yeah.
Thanks so much, David, appreciate it.
All right, Sam.
Sam may have been exercising or using power
tools there, so we're going to let him let
him get back
to it.